new in theaters this weekend abominable
what will you see this is your weekend
ticket you need to spend more time here
with a family where are you going be
back with look it up be careful out
there no boy got a covered by I just
want to escape dad always wanted me to
travel the world someday
[Music]
Oh who's the Yeti on my roof the next
film from DreamWorks comes out this
weekend
abominable when he finds a scared
escaped Yeti hiding at her hideout she
decides to set off on an epic journey to
help it find its family now he and her
friends must stay one step ahead of the
people who took the Yeti from its home
and hopefully make it with the help of a
little bit of magic this movies for you
if you're looking for a movie for the
whole family this weekend you're a fan
of anywhere all of the DreamWorks films
or if you're looking to perfect your
DreamWorks smile you know the one that
the one that's all the smile that's on
all those posters this one I can't do it
thanks
that is your weekend ticket will you see
and check back next week for some Joker